اظهرت وثائق تم تسريبها في عام 2016 ان
الامم المتحده وظفت في السابق اقارب
مسؤولين رفيعي المستوى في النظام منهم
ابنه رئيس المديريه العامه للمخابرات
السوريه حسام لوقا الخاضع للعقوبات وظفتها
في مكتب الصندوق المركزي لمواجهه الطوارئ
التابع للامم المتحده في دمشق وقال عامل
اغاثه للصحيفه ان مسؤولين نظام يجبرونهم
على توظيف اقربائهم وتشير ممارسه التوظيف
هذه الى ان موالين للنظام يسيطرون عمليا
على مكاتب المنظمات الدوليه داخل سوريا
التقرير كشف ايضا ان الامم المتحده دفعت
11.5 مليون دولار في عام 2022
لمصاريف سكن موظفيها في فندق الفور سيزنز
في دمشق المملوك لرجل الاعمال المعروف
سامر فوز والخاضع هو الاخر للعقوبات
للعلم جهود المساعده التي تبذلها اي هيئه
امميه وجميع برامج المساعده في سوريا
المشاهدينا يجب ان توافق عليها الحكومه مع
التدخلات من مختلف الوزارات وفروع
المخابرات حيث تقول مجموعات الاضافه ان
الحصول على هذه التصاريح يمثل عقبه كبيره
امام عملها